What happened?
It's weird.
Do you want to see?
Yes.
Okay.
I can go through the veneration section.
Okay, we can start.
Do I speak like right now?
Yes.
Well, when I saw that you guys were going out, I started to get more nervous because I knew that it was coming up.
Here where I started, I felt that I was in my zone.
I felt that I was going to do a great performance.
Everything good, good.
When I was here, I felt, I don't know, like my movements were not as good as I expected.
So in my mind, I started to fight.
And exactly here, I started to feel that I was going to forget the pomse.
But then I felt that my body had like memory, like...
Muscular memory.
And it was doing it by itself.
And here in the kicks is where I got my mind back where it had to be.
And in the key up, I felt that I had to compensate.